Moving in the darkness of the cosmos is an evil and mysterious planet named Gordus.
This is Starforce.
Starforce. And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. And I'm Joe.
And today we are talking about Starforce, not to be confused with the fictional supervillain team that fight the Avengers.
Do you guys know about Starforce?
I don't. No.
They show up before this game, if you Google search.
A lot of things do, including the Mega Man Starforce series.
It's a pretty generic name.
Wait, this isn't the most popular thing called Starforce?
There's certain points where if you just type in Starforce, you're more likely to get Star Wars, like, Force Awakens.
Or, like, Dark Forces, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's a video game.
That's just how...
Wait, is that really? Dark Forces, right?
Oh, Star Wars, Dark Forces.
Yeah. That's true. That's one of them.
Like... It's up there.
Jedi Knight. Yeah.
Oh, okay. Very cool.
Well, you know, Star Wars games are good again now.
Yeah. Big again, rather.
Not good again. Yeah.
But, you know, what's that Fallen Order?
Yes. Yeah. That's a game.
Probably is. The movies have shit the bed, but we always have the games.
So, they're okay. We always have the old movies, too.
That's the thing. People, you always got 1977.
Yeah. You can make anything you want now.
And we're in 87, and we're talking about Starforce.
Yeah. We'll definitely get into that right away, but I just want to talk real fast, if you don't
mind, about development for the game.
This game was made by Tecmo.
At the time, they were called Tec-Con, but it says Tecmo on their thing, too, so I don't
know why. Maybe they were going through the transition point.
Anyway, we know Tecmo today for Dead or Alive, Ninja Gaiden, Deception.
That's on this list of titles you would know them for, but I certainly don't know them.
And then Rygar is the one that we know them for right now, and Rygar was a solid game,
right? I voted essential.
But nice. I like Rygar a lot.
I still like Rygar.
Fatal Frame. That's another game that Tecmo does.
Oh. And obviously, Tecmo Bowl, which we will get to.
That's right. So, these are all games that Tecmo's known for, but they started, just to get a little
bit into the deep lore of Tecmo.
Tecmo started as the Imperial Trusty Corporation, a company that specialized in the management
of building maintenance, including the supplying of cleaning equipment.
What? So, clearly, they're bound to make video games at some point or another, right?
As they are the corporation responsible for building maintenance.
They also, like, used to trade tea in the, like, South Indies or something?
Right. So, I mean, like, look, Nintendo started as a card company, but that's closer than this.
That's a game thing. Yeah, that's a game thing.
They do eventually, the game connection does happen, though, because in July of 1969, the
company started to sell entertainment amusement equipment.
So, like, things that you would see at an amusement park.
Still a far cry from cleaning equipment.
But they're getting there, you know?
And I just think it's really interesting that, like, they go from, like, this very far away
thing to, like, oh, we make amusement park equipment to let's just start making video
games. People like that.
That's so weird. So, they go from the Imperial Trusty Corporation to Teccon to Tecmo, and now they're Koei Tecmo.
Oh. There was a point where Square was going to buy them, actually, but that fell through, and instead,
Koei got them.
Well, I mean, I think that Square kind of is fine without them, so it's not a big divergence
point. Yes, yes.
And Hudson Soft maybe developed the NES port.
It's listed with them in there, but Tecmo definitely published both the NES and Japanese
version. But Tecmo definitely also made the arcade version.
However, despite the US arcade version being titled Megaforce, Tecmo decided to release the
NES version under the original name Starforce.
Do we have a preference?
Would you have preferred Megaforce?
I think that Starforce is fine.
I think Starforce is better, actually.
I think Starforce is a hair better than Megaforce.
It's... It's like Starforce at least has like a modicum more of like telling you what it is.
Megaforce are just two words that don't mean anything together.
And isn't it funny that there are three Mega Man Starforce games and like Mega and Star
are both in the consideration for this title and then Mega Man just like completely eclipses
them. So whether you search for Megaforce or Starforce, you're going to probably wind up with Mega Man
Starforce one, two, or three on the Game Boy Advance, I think.
Game Boy Advance. All right.
So we can just move into first impressions.
Sean? So Starforce, it's a shmup, right?
Yeah. We should let people know.
It is a shmup. I thought that we would have maybe some brief respite.
It's still going.
So I like to think that, you know, shmups are made in a factory.
And, you know, first you get like a...
You get the template of a shmup and they're just, you know, they're pressed in like into
some kind of material.
And then they go down this assembly line, this conveyor belt, and then they get their
power ups added and they get their levels added.
And I think that in this analogy, Starforce fell off the assembly line right before it got
any of that stuff.
And it really is just the template of a shmup to me.
Okay. Sounds good.
Joe? I was actually going to say exactly what Sean said.
No, I had similar feelings.
I don't know if I was maybe as angry with it because I already have...
I say this every single time, which I just recently realized how often I say this whenever we
play a shmup. But I already have this bias from like another shmup.
So when I got into playing it, I was like, yeah, this is what I expected.
It didn't impress me much, but it felt like just like the purest shmup.
I play a lot of video games and I did not get to play a lot of shmups growing up, but they
did intrigue me.
So I'm not tired of shmups yet.
However, this is just...
This is crazy.
Like we thought 1942 was pretty bare bones and I'm willing to say it's still pretty much
close to the bottom. This game though, it truly is...
It's bizarre at this point, especially coming from the same people that brought us Rygar,
which was so innovative and different and reaching for something.
Now again, like it's probably two different teams within or whatever, but this is just...
It doesn't make any sense, you know, to Sean's point here, where is the rest of the shmup
genre in this game?
Basically, I've seen game maker, you know?
Yeah, exactly. I've seen game maker games that could include more than what Star Force is giving us here.
Like, is it a...
Is this a port or something?
Like when did the arcade version come out?
Was there an arcade version?
There was an arcade version.
And to be honest, it's...
It doesn't look like anything is missing in the NES version in terms of gameplay things.
Like they're still losing the power, the power ups and stuff like that.
Yeah, but was it like a long time ago?
Let's see. Star Force came out in the arcade in 1984.
So yeah. Well, maybe that's why.
Yeah. Why would they...
Why would they publish this game if so many leaps have gone by in this genre?
Money. Yeah.
Maybe it had a name that, you know, people would be like, would buy because they remembered
it or... Or because of Star Wars.
It's close. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
We talked about that with Star Voyager too.
Yeah. Like thinking of Star Wars and Star Trek Voyager.
Right? Just mixing both of them and hoping somebody gets confused and buys it for their kid who
likes Star Wars or Star Trek.
Yeah, Transmorphers. Right. I will say that, you know, coming into this, I'm pretty negative on this game.
But just hearing how negative you guys are, I do feel the need to say my positive thoughts.
I feel like I have a few positive thoughts that you guys might not agree with.
But I thought that it being, at least for like someone who's a fan of shmups, it being so
bare bones, you might still just enjoy, like I still think that it's like a clean gameplay
experience. And yeah, there's not really any power ups.
There's not like anything else to do.
But if you want to just have that like button mashing, dodged, you know, just like the purest shmup
experience, I can see people definitely enjoying this game.
Like, I don't know.
Yeah. I think it's definitely not for me, especially because it's a genre I don't care for with
nothing extra about it.
But I can see like someone who's just like, I just want to just try and shoot things without
any like extra help or anything like that.
And it is a pretty tough game too.
It's an important viewpoint to have.
I don't know if I'd agree with tough game.
I think I think.
Well, here's the thing.
It's tough because they don't give you any of those power ups that we're used to in shmups.
But I would offer that this game is like a training for like getting better at shmups because
you have to just get better at anticipating your targets and knowing when, where, you know,
like where they're going to be versus shooting where they are because that's like the first,
you know, lesson in shmups.
Yeah, it feels like it's very much based on like your skill, like nothing else.
There's like one power up, but like nothing else is going to help you.
You're just you have to dodge those bullets.
You have to. And the one power up is a rapid fire, right?
Which a turbo button could have solved.
And that being said, though, I think that's I think we're we're alluding to an idea that
this game, while it's bland and really doesn't offer anything new is still like really competent.
And yet it's it doesn't have any huge bugs and it's it doesn't have huge slowdown.
But there's a design.
There's a design decision with with the use of color in this game, which makes it really hard for like significant portions where all of the projectiles that are coming for you are almost like just a shade off of the background where you're they're shooting white projectiles at you on just off white ground below them.
And it's just really hard to keep track of everything, especially if you have like if you're a little colorblind or something.
And this is a problem uniform across all versions of the game.
This thing did get ported around a lot.
But even the original arcade version has that problem of just like not being even aesthetically pleasing.
You know, I think the tiles on on what would you call them like asteroids or whatever?
Yeah, the tiles on asteroids look is just not a great look.
And, you know, not not to like knock on the enemies or anything like that.
But they're also they're determined in patterns and in waves.
And so they don't like they don't offer any element of surprise.
And they're very uninteresting.
Right. There's like there's like a very you I feel like I only played to like level three or four or something.
I feel like I already mean gamma.
Yes. Sorry.
I'm forgetting to use the Greek alphabet.
Yeah. We can dive into that later.
But yeah, I think I'm granted there could be more later on.
But I feel like even on those four levels, there's like not much variety.
I just kept seeing all the same enemies.
Yeah. And eventually like the big idea and I'm joking, but I'm saying like the only sense of variety is that in the later stages, some might come from behind you.
Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
And then you have to just dodge them because you can't shoot behind you.
So it's like, thanks.
But Section Z even figured out, oh, that should happen like right away and you should be able to shoot behind you as well.
Like and that game came out into the arcades in like 85, 86.
So there's really no excuse here.
And I get the whole like, you know, just a raw shmup.
I just don't think that if you're going to do that, if you're going to just have it be like, you know, you're a spaceship and you have to go against, you know, an entire army with no power ups or anything like that.
But you have to do something in terms of like maneuverability or weapon, not weapon diversity, enemy diversity or, you know, exploration diversity.
Because even like being if you could move from side to side in the screens, but you're just locked to the screen you're on is so little going on that it's not a very pleasant experience to keep trucking through even if you wanted to.
There's not enough happening here to stimulate the mind.
You actually don't even get to go all around the screen that you're on.
Yeah, there's a there's like a force field that stops you from going to where the enemies are.
And I don't know that can be an issue, too, though.
I mean, I don't know why you'd be up there to begin with unless you're trying to evade a lot of a lot of enemies.
But if if the only direction you can go is in that direction, then you're fucked.
Right. And it's true because even even a game like 1942 would let you go all the way to the top of the screen.
It wasn't recommended because enemies appear there was no invisible barrier.
It's very strange.
Yeah, I mean, I will say, like I said, I was not a fan of this game.
I just wanted to put out the parts that I thought like why I could see some people liking it.
You have to be very specific type of person, I think.
But but yeah, I didn't think it was great.
Although I did. I would.
I think I would take this over 1942.
I don't know if you guys feel the same.
OK, no, I like 1942.
I like that theme.
At least at least it has.
What was the theme for 1942?
No, no, not the music.
The music was terrible. Oh, yeah, because the music was like.
No, yeah, yeah. You mean World War II?
Yeah, that's right.
That's right. No, I meant like, you know, yeah, World War II.
The theme of World War II. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I prefer that over this.
But if we want to get into that, this has a pretty cool story in the manual.
It has in the year 2010.
10. Just setting way, way into the future.
Of Dimension Almanac.
It's like, is that the book?
Dimension Almanac?
And then like it describes all the dimensions?
Or like, anyway. In the year 2010 of Dimension Almanac, there was a mysterious planet named Gordas, which was moving in the darkness of the cosmos for the purpose of mass murder and wonder.
The planet itself.
Yeah, it was going to, yeah, I guess like steal from the planet, the other planets.
The poor and get to the race. Yeah, the people of the planets, who knows?
Everyone gave up fighting against Gordas because of its awesome power.
I love when awesome is used to refer to things that are like big or like.
Truly awesome. Yeah, like the actual original definition of awesome.
Yeah, like people might say like, oh, Thanos is awesome, right?
But they're more talking about like the character.
But to describe Thanos' power as awesome is like a different kind of awesome.
It's cool. Like in awe, right?
Yeah, like in awe of how much power he holds.
Honestly, what a great paragraph this is.
Yeah, it keeps giving.
It keeps giving. So everyone gave up fighting against Gordas because of its awesome power.
One day, a brave soldier riding a space patroller challenged Gordas to a fight.
People called this space patroller Final Star.
Such a great name.
Wishing to be saved.
You must bring an end to the murders which have been committed for the past 2,000 years.
This is just so strange though.
I'm just amazed they keep using the word murder.
Yeah, murder is very strange.
That's what it's goal. He just wants to murder.
Continue. No, that's it.
But also like I'm confused because does that mean since the year 10 there's just been murder
from Planet Gordas?
It was in the Bible.
Well, this is an alternate dimension.
It's in dimension all in that. This is all in action.
We're not there. Oh, so 2010 is just somebody else's 2010.
Yeah, but they do have the Greek alphabet.
Right. So Athens was a thing but not necessarily religion.
Okay. Yeah. Wait, maybe we are in, I'm sorry, not Project Almanac.
Dimension Almanac.
This is Dimension Almanac and, you know, Mega Man happens in Dimension textbook.
book yeah yeah and so as we're alluding to with the greek alphabet thing each stage in the game is named
after a letter in the greek alphabet so you start with alpha and beta and gamma gamma delta and you
work your way through this until you get to omega but at the at the end of each level there's an end
of level boss oh wow finally something different right no they don't even fight back no it's just
like a thing you have to shoot it's just there i can't believe they're even describing them as
boss fights like they're not boss fights the bosses have no offensive abilities other than
collision don't run into them but shoot them for sure but but they do at least have an original
design for each level yes and well yeah they have they have the the greek letter on no yeah
but an original design right i'm saying they each just have the same two cannons that fire a few
shots at your ship does that go through because i assumed because i didn't get very far i was like
oh the later levels must have yeah crazier i don't think they do no same two cannons okay good they
have they have a new letter yes a different letter each time that's what i'm in it for what's gonna be
next well you know too because the stage tells you which stage you're on but after omega after
beating the same boss 25 times now you're on stage 26 which is just the infinity sign oh and you would
think like wow now i've really pushed the game to its limits no that just means you'll be playing this
level on loop per infinity just that level just that level for infinite loops wow that's that's really
that's that's actually pretty profound right it's almost like you think you've beaten um the gordis
but really you have to just keep it occupied for eternity it's like the end of dr strange all you've
yeah all you've done is gordis has tricked you into into thinking you've won but you actually die and
now you just repeat the same level over and over again infinity all right i actually think that this
is a brilliant game now it's a yeah it's actually the ending of mass effect 3 don't spoil it i've
heard how great it is were you serious i haven't played it i haven't played it he hasn't played any
of them i won't spoil it but i think that you know what it's funnier thinking that as you get close to
working your way through the trilogy you're gonna be like oh but i know how star force ends
so that's an interesting twist like someone someone did that to me in the past where they set me up to
believe that an ending to something that i didn't know yet was gonna be like something and it turned
out to be nothing like that and that was like a very nice thing they did because it totally like
shocked me when it didn't happen that way wow anyway was it me it wasn't you oh it will never be you
god damn but it's also simultaneously always you in gordis's dimension almanac do we have anything
else we want to talk about when it comes to gameplay here what gameplay oh no trying to think
it's gotta be something you shoot bullets you shoot bullets and rapidly shoot bullets at certain points
yeah you know it's weird to me that there even is that power up for the rapidly shoot bullets because
there are no other power ups you could also just tap the button it would do the same thing it's
i couldn't do it as quickly as the well i think you could also just have a rapid button you know if
you had like a turbo controller or something i'll mention two things there there is a tips and tricks
section in the manual and uh this is not one of those tips and tricks but i think it's worth mentioning
this game is so formulaic to the point where you can determine which direction the end level boss
will move before it even appears by just looking at your score if the hundred digits is an odd number
the boss will move to the left and if it's an even number it'll move to the right wow that's cheating
i don't i don't think that's fair that's cheap yeah i honestly i can't believe you would do that yeah we're
talking about um kid nicky last week and then we were cheesing that game there's a section of it
nobody bats an eye this is here this is just for a game this polished well you know what's funny is
in this game too like points points i guess matter right if if it's if it's a raw shmup and you're it's
an arcade style thing a score might matter to someone not if you just have to play the game forever right
and most things are worth like a thousand points or you know a few hundred points there is a way to get
one million points by just one particular object it's only available at one point so when you get
to the violet continent and you see back up here i don't know what stage it's on but it's it's a
violet color i thought it was like this is what it's called and you were expecting us to like know
the violet like the asteroid the violet asteroid uh you see this fossil on the left side if you go
to the right of the fossil and shoot at it cleopatra will appear like just just the face of cleopatra
will appear shoot her and you'll get a million point bonus so these game designers were staunch
anti-cleopatra yeah and she also exists in their dimension which also what's confusing is that's why
i was thinking it's the same dimension these are but we're following the greek alphabet but now we're
using egyptian characters well greece and egypt were actually they actually shared a lot of uh
culture and trade that explains why assassin's creed origins then went to odyssey yes yes go bills great
that's the only things i have from the tips and tricks section and that one actually is called
out in the manual that like shoot cleopatra for a million points like secret thing it's just like
in the manual it's referred to as like the seven mysteries of star force and that's number seven
is like can you find the coveted million point bonus cleopatra well if you can shoot her in the face
i think we have to move right into sequels and spinoffs there were do it great there were yes
and then there were two wow yeah um both japanese only i'm i'm pretty sure the first one super star
force which is released in 1986 for the famicom so it came out before even this one comes out
in north america do they keep their austere like no nothing design you know i looked at it and i want
to say yes you know like i'm sure it includes something extra but let's see what is it what
do we got what do we got here star force unlike most shoot-em-ups released during its time star
super star force is a combination of a shoot-up and an adventure game players must go back in time in
order to defeat gordis again however seven time stones must be collected from each level's hidden dungeon
you're making an adventures joke no this is legit
taking advantage of the time travel opportunities during the game can help to unravel the mysteries of
time and space players have to simply repeat the actions of the distant pass in order to progress
all right so it's it's got something yeah that's something different i'm actually now very curious
yeah that sounds interesting you go through different time periods you start in zero zero zero
zero one three zeros and then one that's called the ending of the fetal movement and this is the
legendary underground slave owning empire of erujineba exists near a vast number of distinctive
volcanoes what this is an nes game this is an nes game then you go to 316 genesis this era is
characterized by rugged mountains and huge pieces of inorganic ground materials 820 the dawn
filled with numerous monuments to the past this level is the most important in the game
the entrance to the era dorara forest demon ruins have been closed the key to opening it is the
statue of dorara mike are you reading copy or are you reading like what's what somebody like
described is somebody describing the game on a forum right now or no this is on wikipedia
so i have to play this game if we're being honest this is an nes game this is an nes game i wish it
wasn't a shmup right with time travel it's actually an rpg now yeah it's time travel and uh it's also
shmup and it's also an action game i'm in so we will play this game no no it only ever comes to japan
but i have to go home and play this game like tonight i have to order it or something uh
and what's funny is this is this was supposed to be the bigger thing but now it seems like the time
travel thing is just awesome if you go to the manual for star force you will see that they say
that super star force is coming soon i didn't notice that oh no they are so cocky about how this game is
going to perform that they're already teasing super star force because it's already out in japan 1986
so like yeah look out for super star force the game that never comes i think that's funny to like
tease that in a manual and then just be like yeah we we don't have the funds the first vaporware huh
yep and then in 1992 just for the arcades we get final star force still gordis is um
his name is still gordis yeah it's still gordis gordis um this is a millennia ago a mysterious force
known as gordis perished in a long battle so now it's a thousand years after 2010 we are the history
now yes uh however gordis has been brought back to life by a race of aliens known as the borigan
are they talking about a planet still or are they the planet yeah the planet gordis it's brought back
to life it's brought back to life okay and it's now in the process of ravaging the earth an entire
planet is now ravaging another planet two spaceships the blue nova and the red nova are sent to fight
the borigan forces and destroy gordis so the gameplay of the final star force goes back to the formula of
the original star force but with updated graphics and finally some extra power-ups and pvp yeah so
that's good other things that have been changed from the original are the style of the title screen's
logo we've all been asking for that yeah wikipedia could be so specific at times but nobody asks for
it either anyway it's clear star force is not a franchise that people are demanding and 1992 marks the
end of star force so we might as well just mark this the end of us talking about this and move right
into the essential games list well if it didn't give it away that we've been talking more about
the sequels and spinoffs than the gameplay of the original game sean please tell me your vote for the
essential games list when it comes to star force my vote is no it is inessential this is the template for
a denial of entry into the essential games list nice joe yeah i'm also gonna go with it with a with a no
on this one um i still do think that there are people out there that will enjoy this but i think
you you are gonna say that about every game at this point is that like they're listening and they're
like why do you keep talking about us like we're lepers there's some freaks out there no i just mean i just
mean that like i still think i i think to me saying it's worse than 1942 i i thought 1942 is still like
the lowest of the shmups that we've played but i think just because it's like it's just it's just
about your skill with it like i think if you are really into shmups you might have a mediocre time
with this let me clarify with that um but i don't think it's necessarily going to be horrible i didn't
like it at all and if you're if you're not a huge fan of shmups i definitely don't think you're
like it you made this like it less than us one thing i forgot to mention just about the way i
played this maybe it'll give you a better idea of the kind of gameplay it is you know in a movie
when they're when they're showing a video game but you you you understand that like the whoever made
this movie doesn't know how video game how it looks to play a video game that's how i look when
i'm playing this video game it's like so button mashy to me so i'm not very good at this game
maybe that has to has to do with why i didn't like it very much no it didn't okay and also yes
it's not a great game but it's still okay to some people who might like shmups stand by it
star force is like if in super mario brothers all you could do is jump there were there was nothing
like there was no fire flower yeah there was flat land there was no platforming it's like in a jrpg
where you never upgrade your combat gear and you're just and you can't change your classes
there's no magic system right the character you are at the beginning is the character you are at
the end of the game you didn't grow up at all or anything just a random battle generator this
really is just a story about you know a guy who challenged a planet and single-handedly not only
won but knew he was going to win from the beginning he didn't he didn't upgrade himself he didn't he
didn't win he didn't work well oh yeah that's right he just goes into the infinity zone oh my gosh
the infinity zone infinity stones this whole episode has been nothing but avengers there's a team
called star force that fights the avengers wow this is getting crazy anyway the vote is obviously no
i'm still waiting to play star force like you know i don't know what i experienced but it's the
equivalent of you know when you watch like when when you stay on the title screen too long and then
the game just starts playing itself that's what that's what i essentially did during my time playing
star force is i felt like i was watching the game play itself but it was really just me playing it
doing nothing you had dissociative episode while playing this game right and i'm i i think that super
star force sounds awesome and i know it can't possibly deliver yeah on what it's offering but
it sounds like star force meets chrono trigger that's what i was thinking the whole time which
is just impossible so uh my vote is no but i'm definitely going to check out super star force
that is all the time we have for this episode of nostalgia join us next time where we do another
great nes game in chronological order uh if you're wondering what that game is i'm stalling to
find out as well but while we're stalling why don't you check out www.nostalgiacast.com sean what
can they find there they can find every episode that we have ever recorded and we can also you can
also read the manuals no not the manuals we have we have we have articles about things yeah we have
articles we have a few and also from the website you can type in you can search in the search bar at
the top at the url for the manuals and read the manuals that way you could do that that's just your
browser but like yeah we have those things we have links to cool things great we have a contact form
which you can use to get in touch with us yeah uh please do the uh also what was i gonna say was
not important no that you were gonna say what the next the next game was super pitfall is our next game
so you guys all remember pitfall big game on the atari 2600 some say it invented a genre it didn't
uh but sure pitfall whatever that's how indifferent i am but super pitfall sounds like it's gonna be a
blast it's like pac-man but then you hear you got super pac-man and you're like oh what what needed
must be superior right so we'll play that for sure and you'll join us next friday i'm michael esposito
you can find me on at esposito film on twitter and i hope you're having a great uh time
you and now it's time for the post show about kid nicky guys we haven't talked about kid nicky for a week
okay what's going on i have a completely you know what i got a t-shirt that somebody made
i it may have been my roommate that made the t-shirt but it's a kid nicky t-shirt going forward i'd like to
have a 15 minute meeting every morning just on our outlook calendars that just says kid nicky
you don't have to meet yeah you know like we don't have to talk about it or anything i just
want that 15 minute meeting that shows up in your like you know laptop just to remind you of like oh
yeah kid nicky is a game that exists and i should be thinking about it yeah no that's why i got the
shirt very similar to how like i'll call joe every now and again and just be like don't forget that
kingdom hearts 3 came out no we can't wait for it anymore you guys aren't going far enough i'm
getting a tattoo on my palm that says kid nicky oh just you can always it's like a memento yeah
yeah it'll say kid nicky and the date that the episode came out right well yes that's funny so
funny this way you remember all the good times we had recording the episode and just to remind myself
that it exists yeah you're punishing yourself for just being a part of the universe where it exists
yeah by constantly reminding yourself about it you're doing a great job of it right now right i'm
helping every sunday instead of meditating now i actually just go on top of a rock squat there for
a unlimited amount of time hoping that like you know like there's like enlightenment with the buddha
i'm hoping that like by squatting on that rock for a certain time eventually i'll just be teleported to
a secret area well don't forget your secret stabbing technique which is if you drop something you can pick
it up that's uh that's a good way to end this thank you for humoring us we are so sorry that we did
this to whoever listens um good night or morning but not afternoon but not afternoon please do listen
to this in the afternoon yeah we're very disappointed you know what the favorite time for me to play kid
nicky is is right in the afternoon the best time to play kid that's why you shouldn't be listening to
this right now if it's the afternoon you should be playing kid nicky the best time to play kid nicky
is all the time
right back at you